also stört mich schon sehr stören ich
finde es einigermaßen bezeichnung des
urlaubsortes trotzdem nicht daran denkt
ein rot-rot-grünes bündnis
auszuschließen nicht dass jetzt
ultimativ daran glaube dass es passiert
aber ich finde wenn es schon so
staatsmännisch gibt und nehmen wir
angela merkel zwei sein möchte sollte
doch auch irgendwie ist es jetzt nicht
kraft worten wie sich ausdrücken sollten
den mut haben zu sagen er kult auch
nicht mit der zumindest teilweise extrem
linken politischen ecke und das land
macht
insofern spannend dass die weder oder
die menschen jetzt den umfragen sind
befragt wurden ein bisschen übernehmen
also schon absurd also auch nach dieser
woche abstimmung über afghanistan die
wir kennen die position der linken aber
selbst bei dem mandat jetzt für unsere
soldaten die unter einsatz ihres lebens
dort sowohl eigene staatsbürger und
ortskräfte rausholen noch nicht mal das
mandat im bundestag zu geben und damit
enthaltung zustimmen spätestens da ist
schluss und erreichen auch keine helmut
helmut schmidt nostalgie endlich josi
wird dass er so tut weh das tut
natürlich das ist nicht dass es nicht
gegen ihn wird wundert mich auch sehr
dass heißt das thema ist nicht mehr
tabuisiert in deutschland es läuft
einfach so aber nimmt aber eine einer
der grund ist natürlich frau teuteberg
die da sitzt also wenn die spd in einer
ampelkoalition mit der fdp koalieren
will muss sie eine theoretisch ein
kleines ratespiel
androhen können damit die fdp nicht
neben dem finanzminister im
außenministerium oder sonstwas verlangen
darf nicht die einzige option was soll
eine partei an die macht so weiter
versehen aber ich finds halbzeit und ich
verstehe es total war praktisch zu sagen
nicht auszuschließen man braucht ein
druckmittel fällen aber dann sich so zu
drücken und herum zu eiern und sagen ja
eher schwierig weil die prinzipien
stehen nato
transatlantische beziehung und alles
ganz fix und das ist ja schwierig aber
nein kann man trotz mit sagen also das
ist so könnte es nicht auch einfach sein
dass dieses schreckensszenario rot rot
grün nicht verfängt weil kein mensch
glaubt dass das oberhaupt scholz
wirklich rot oder grün machen würde als
hamburger bürgermeister hamburger
sozialdemokrat jemand der jetzt so viele
jahre finanzminister war die
staatsfinanzen auch ganz ordentlich
gemanagt hat daher keine sozialistischen
umtriebe gezeigt hat vielleicht glaubt
der cdu einfach niemand dass olaf scholz
jemand rot-rot-grünen machen würde
selbst wenn das nicht ausschließt wenn
er gar keine anderen möglichkeiten hätte
also will sein risiko nicht einen
kleinen freiheit würde glaube ich für
den fall das geht nicht haben das ist ja
das ist ja das ist ja das ja wenn
kühnert und saskia esken sind auch noch
da und ich bin ich wieder da
und da sind ja dass er mit dieser
strategie der linken stimmen wegnimmt
die ist jetzt noch bei 6 prozent in
umfragen die wollte mal zweistellig
werden dass alles vorbei ist sagt dass
alles auf aber ich einen teil seines
vaters muss man einmal sagen man kann
jetzt olaf schulz nicht vorwerfen dass
er alles ausnutzt um erfolgreich zu sein
man kann der maximale erfolg ist diese
frage nicht zu beantworten
ist ja auch klar dass man nicht über
seine quasi leichen im keller spricht
wenn wenn ein mann beschließt würde das
problem ist raum nach oben dünner nach
hause holen erzählt auch nicht dass er
zuhause giftschlangen und skorpione
freiheit also das
bedeutet man sagt doch nicht seine
schlechtest möglichen eigenschaften
sondern man sagt doch ich bin der größte
wo wir wollen uns ja auch damit sie
wählen das hat doch auch damit zu tun
wenn die union jetzt sagt warnt vor
linksbündnis rote socken und so das
verfängt auch deshalb nicht mehr weil
wer glaubt ihr noch dass sie für
marktwirtschaft steht dass auch der
andere punkt also ja und das ist auch
nicht mehr so eine begrifflichkeit über
den socken und sowas als er muss die
sehr feinsinnig liberale betracht ja ja
aber ich finde dass die rote socken
kampagne wieder ausgräbt kann man doch
das irgendwie die möglichkeit benennen
dass ich rot rot grün geben könnte das
könnte das thema aber sehr wenn also
oftmals angenommen aus ihrer sicht die
unterstellung ist ja im moment und die
kann man durchaus erheben olaf scholz
möchte heimlich rot-rot-grün in seiner
partei wollen da sicher einige es könnte
aber auch sein dass olaf scholz
tatsächlich nicht rot rot grün machen
möchte ist er dann eigentlich
verpflichtet das öffentlich zu sagen
wenn er tief in seinem herzen das nicht
will warum sollte er das dann eigentlich
war also wäre für wäre blöd weil er so